SO AS WE SAID, LET'S PULL UP IF
WE COULD THESE IMAGES BECAUSE
THIS IS STRIKING AND SO
IMPORTANT TO SEE THIS IS A
JOURNALIST IN AMERICAN
JOURNALISTS. YES, THIS IS EVAN
HERSKOVITS. HE IS 32 YEARS OLD.
HE IS BEHIND PLEXIGLASS IN A
COURTROOM IN MOSCOW, APPEALING
HIS DETENTION ON ESPIONAGE
CHARGES. OBVIOUSLY THE UNITED
STATES, SAYING HE HAS BEEN
WRONGFULLY DETAINED. THE U. S.
AND HE AND HIS FAMILY AND THE
WALL STREET JOURNAL ALL
VEHEMENTLY DENYING THESE CHARGES
. LET'S GET STRAIGHT TO MATTHEW
CHANCE LIVE IN LONDON WITH MORE
TO SEE HIM IS SO IMPORTANT AND
THE QUESTION BECOMES NOW WHAT
HAPPENS IN THAT COURTROOM? YEAH
IT'S INCREDIBLE, ISN'T IT?
BECAUSE REMEMBER, I THINK THIS
IS THE FIRST TIME WE'VE CAUGHT A
GLIMPSE OF HEAVEN. GORSHKOV ITCH
SINCE HE WAS DETAINED BY THE
RUSSIAN AUTHORITIES AT THE END
OF MARCH, SINCE, OF COURSE, BEEN
ACCUSED OF ESPIONAGE, AN
ALLEGATION THAT HE IS DENIED IN
HIS VARIOUS COURT APPEARANCES.
AND, OF COURSE, WHICH IS PAPER
THAT HE WORKS FOR THE WALL
STREET JOURNAL, ALSO VEHEMENTLY
DENIED AS WELL. BUT YOU CAN SEE
HIM STANDING THERE, HIS ARMS
FOLDED, WEARING THAT PLAYED
SHIRT WEARING JEANS, SMILING. AT
THE PHOTOGRAPHERS AND THE
JOURNALISTS THAT HAVE BEEN
ALLOWED IN FOR A SHORT PERIOD TO
CATCH A GLIMPSE OF HIM AND TAKE
THEIR PHOTOGRAPHS. YOU DIDN'T
SAY ANYTHING. AS FAR AS I'M
AWARE BEFORE THE REPORTERS WERE
ASKED BY THE COURT TO LEAVE.
THEY HAVE NOW BEEN ASKED TO
LEAVE AND ARE OUTSIDE. THE U. S
AMBASSADOR IS THEY'RE EXPECTING
SOME REMARKS FROM HER SHORTLY AS
WELL. IN TERMS OF WHAT THIS
HEARING IS ABOUT. THIS ISN'T TO
APPEAL. HIS ARREST OR THE
CHARGES AGAINST HIM. THIS IS TO
DECIDE WHETHER IT'S THE RIGHT
THING THAT HE SHOULD BE
CONTINUED TO BE HELD IN THAT TOP
SECURITY PRISON IN THE CENTER OF
MOSCOW. LEFORTOVO JAIL, HIS
LAWYERS ARGUING HE SHOULD BE PUT
IN HOUSE ARREST OR SOME OTHER
KIND OF FACILITY. AND SO THE
AUTHORITIES ARE GOING TO DECIDE
THAT. BUT I HAVE TO SAY GIVEN
THAT THESE CHARGES OF ESPIONAGE
AGAINST HIM, WHETHER WHETHER
THEY'RE VALID OR NOT. THE FACT
THAT THESE ARE SERIOUS CHARGES,
IT IS HIGHLY UNLIKELY THAT THE
COURT IS GOING TO, FOR INSTANCE
, ALLOW HERSKOVITS TO GO INTO
HOUSE RED, BUT WE'LL SEE. IT'LL
BE ABOUT AN HOUR WE EXPECT IS
WHAT WE'RE BEING TOLD BY THE
COURT ABOUT AN HOUR BEFORE WE
KNOW WHAT THE COURT DECIDES ON
THIS APPEAL REGARDING EVAN
GORSKI, WHICH IS DETENTION. YEAH
AT FIRST, IT WASN'T WE WEREN'T
SURE IF HE WAS GOING TO APPEAR
LIVE THERE OR VIA VIDEO LINK.
BUT AGAIN, AS YOU POINTED OUT,
THIS IS A CITY COURT, THE MOSCOW
CITY COURT. THEY COULD HAVE ALL
MR GERT. CEVICHES. CONTINUED
PRETRIAL DETENTION, THEY COULD
ORDER HIM MOVED TO ANOTHER JAIL.
THEY COULD LOWER HOUSE ARREST AS
YOU SAID, OR GRANT HIM BAIL,
WHICH IS UNLIKELY IN THIS CASE,
BUT THIS IS A PRE TRIAL
DETENTION HEARING UNTIL MAY,
29TH AND THEN BEYOND THAT
RUSSIAN AUTHORITIES CAN EXTEND
HE LOOKS FAIRLY HEALTHY,
ALTHOUGH WE'RE JUST LOOKING AT
HIM, OBVIOUSLY CAN'T EXAMINE HIM
PHYSICALLY WITH HIS ARMS.
THEY'RE FOLDED. A LITTLE NERVOUS
, YOU KNOW, WALKING AROUND AND
YOU KNOW A SMILE AT ONE POINT,
POSSIBLY PEOPLE HE KNEW AS A
JOURNALIST JOURNALIST, BUT WHAT
DO WE KNOW ABOUT WHERE HE'S
BEING HAILED HELD AND THE
CONDITIONS UNDER WHICH HE IS
BEING HELD? IT'S INTERESTING
BECAUSE IT'S ONLY YESTERDAY THAT
US DIPLOMATS HAVE BEEN GRANTED
CONSULAR ACCESS TO EVAN
HERSKOVITS, WHICH IS AN
EXTRAORDINARY LONG TIME SINCE
THE END OF MARCH THAT THEY
WEREN'T ALLOWED TO SEE HIM AND
SO WE GOT THE FIRST CONSULAR
VISIT YESTERDAY, THE U. S
AMBASSADOR LYNNE TRACY, SAYING
THAT HE APPEARED TO BE HEALTHY
AND LOOK STRONG AFTER AFTER THAT
MEETING, YOU CAN. YOU CAN SEE
THAT FOR YOURSELF. HE SEEMS TO
BE IN IN PRETTY PRETTY GOOD
SPIRITS GIVEN GIVEN HIS
CIRCUMSTANCES, HE IS BEING HELD
IN ONE OF RUSSIA'S MOST
NOTORIOUS PRETRIAL DETENTION
CENTERS, ONE OF ITS MOST
NOTORIOUS PRISONS. IT'S CALLED
LEFORTOVO. IT'S SEVERAL 100
YEARS OLD. IT'S APPARENTLY BEEN
RENOVATED WITHIN THE PAST FEW
YEARS, BUT IT DOES HAVE THIS
NOTORIOUS REPUTATION FOR BEING
THE PLACE WHERE RUSSIAN
DISSIDENTS RUSSIAN POLITICAL
PRISONERS. SOME OF THE MOST
SERIOUS CRIMINALS IN THE COUNTRY
ARE PROCESSED BEFORE THEY STAND
TRIAL AND SENT TO A VARIOUS
PENAL COLONY